name a popular action
and superhero
spider-man
spider-man is number two
batman
batman is number three superman number
one
26. um
iron man
he didn't make it wonder woman
[ __ ] loser did not make it
wolverine
god damn go for it
robin
robin is on the board
[Music]
[Laughter]
get on his face dude
this is how it happened in my head
i said
uh i said uh iron man
then you were like wonder woman or some
[ __ ] and then you said robin i'm like
this [ __ ] just throwing an enhancer
away that's right i said
[Laughter]
answering this question
it has to be boomers
you know what
we [ __ ] up i should have known boomers
were the only ones who know family feud
because only a boomer would answer that
yeah like young man don't even know who
robin
when's the last time robin been in a
movie
robin when's the last it's not even
robin
it's not even robin now it's night arc
it depends it depends on what yeah but
we switched we're not our robin no more
bro that's wild bro
that's funny
that's what i can tell from all the
answers by the way that it is it's
boomers what happens at boomers boat
insurance the reason why they're not
thinking about medical insurance i'm
about to die anyways [ __ ] so
give me a boat entrance instead bruh
i may die but at least my boat gets
phone insurance boomers first
we just live with a cracks creed all our
lives we're like [ __ ] robin
that's wild there's one left right
there's one left
let's go be so bold
keep in mind after robin catwoman
catwoman
okay
these are boomers there are no there are
no females no female true true
oh
that's funny you know what's funny i was
gonna say black panther because it's
boomers i know it's not no it's not that
naggers
what would boomers watch
aquaman
no
no that's too recent no it's not that
the flesh
flash
there's a bit of a theme going around
all these
yeah yeah yeah something with man
a lot of them have been
um
look at that the insurance one for some
reason i feel
that's a very vague hit
yeah i don't know phone insurance is i
feel like it's tied to this a little
just say it captain america
that that should have been my accident
man not man
very patriotic robin
yeah goddamn he came in at number four
robin was number four a wolf captain
his mother was like harassed
[Laughter]
it offends me
it's offensive that's offensive that's
offensive okay